the film the many saints of newark we
talked about it with ray liotta last
week and now we're going to talk about
it with the man who plays the role of
junior soprano in the much anticipated
prequel to david chase's groundbreaking
drama series on hbo the sopranos and the
many saints of newark available in
theaters on hbo max on october first i'm
also enjoying this man's work immensely
on billions on showtime where he plays
the role of mike prince he is the actor
corey stahl how are you corey
i'm good i'm good how are you doing i am
doing better for talking to you uh my
gosh how does one prepare to play uncle
june um you know in this prequel walk me
through that one cory stole well i mean
it's an embarrassment of riches in terms
of the source material
um
you know the
the task was to
play this
very
beloved
very um
uh recognizable by the by the fans this
character and
so i watched the show um
and you know this is my when i was cast
i had seen it every episode twice so i
sat back and
quickly been through a third time um but
you know but really focusing it on
dominant q a dudes
amazing performance um
and just you know i was i was trying to
you know
get as much as i could but
you know by the time you show up on set
try to
try to be so sort of bathed in his
cadences and rhythms and
uh physicality that
i'm not really thinking about those
choices and just
trying to be you know
not a not just a caricature but sure
that's an extension of of the role well
it's it's it's interesting corey some
many people when i say i have to watch
football for a living on a sunday like i
you know like you like hey i have to
watch the sopranos for my job like that
literally was part of your life at one
point i mean that's it it was it was it
was you know
yeah there's definitely some some jobs
where
the research can be uh a grind um and
you're you know you're reading stuff
that's not necessarily
your cup of tea but um
this was this was
something i definitely would love to do
and you know i'm sure
i'll go through it all the fourth time
i'm sure and uh obviously you're you're
one to know exactly what great amazing
remarkable television looks like what
was your favorite
sopranos episode which one when you were
watching it you're like okay that is it
that we should hang that in the louvre
like that's that's a museum piece
which one is which one is that for you
it's so it's so hard to choose um
yeah i mean my god
it really it
you know i could pick a few you know i
think uh obviously the the you know the
russian guy in the
in the woods um pine barrels
directed uh
they're so brilliant
you know
uh
i i think you know the episode where uh
when christopher dies i think it's
really amazing you know that whole last
season was so amazing i mean
what was incredible about the show was
the
was the arc of it of the whole thing you
know
uh
the
the all the different facets that you
saw tony
from seeing it in in one family and then
another and then on the
therapist couch
um
you know
those three sort of
prisms there was to see this one
character
gave opportunity for one of the richest
most complex characters in all of
fiction i think i i i think that is not
an exaggeration corey stoll um i i i
definitely
agree with you and the crazy thing is i
just remember when the sopranos first
came out it was on the heels of the de
niro billy crystal film analyze this and
i i honestly thought well i guess
they're gonna make a serious version of
analyze this and and then
and then i realized oh my god this is
you know godfather goodfellas this is
this is that great and i cannot wait for
the many saints of newark coming out
again on october 1st in theaters and on
hbo max and
what what can you reveal i know that
this is the sort of stuff that
that is omerta to use i guess the phrase
but what can you reveal for us as well
i mean corey it uh
uh it takes place over
what the eight to ten year period
starting in the
late 60s going into the early
70s um
and you you know you get to see
that world that uh
tony was
was yearning for from even from the very
from the pilot you know where where you
know all the gangsters wore suits and
there were no ricoh laws and uh
you know you see
you see the golden you know the golden
age and you see that it really was not
uh so golden
um
uh
and i think it's i think you know david
chase and alan taylor and lawrence
connor who who co-wrote the script
they did such a great job
making a movie that really stands on its
own it really is just like a great
gangster movie with all these new
characters that uh you haven't seen
before
and
for
the
you know the uber
fan i think it'll be
just
so much
fun to
revisit these characters and to get a
sort of a new uh insight into into
these families corey stahl here on the
rich eisen show he plays the role of
junior soprano in the many saints of
newark available in theaters and again
on hbo max on october 1st and
you know the prequel what a genius idea
from david chase but did you ever at any
point in time
pull him aside or just chit chat have a
have a quiet moment with him and asked
him
i know what you're gonna ask yes is
is
you know did did the the guy in the
members only jean jackets whack uh tony
in the in the in the diner do you have
any moments like that corn uh i i i i
knew very well that i wasn't gonna get
anywhere
you didn't even take the shot you didn't
even take the shot huh you didn't take
the shot you know what it i like i don't
wanna i don't wanna know um i i think
i've never
had the
emotional reaction
to a piece of fiction that looks like i
did uh
when when the screen turned black uh at
the end of
this season seven you know i
i was on the edge of my seat my jaw on
the floor
in this incredible state of suspension
the closest thing i think i've
experienced too is maybe watching an
amazing like
you know
[Music]
you're [ __ ] sports
um
that level of engagement um and
that's
that's all that's
you know what what more could you
possibly ask for from a from a piece of
fiction than to actually
move you like that
um
you know i
you know i i i can i tend to think that
he died but i don't it's you know if if
david chase told me tomorrow that he
didn't still
would make that moment you know 100
words it has
like
being
one of the most remarkable moments in
television ever i i wish i had that sort
of reaction corey uh i couldn't i wasn't
i wasn't afforded it because my wife and
everybody else that was at the watch
party in my house thought that i forgot
to pay the direct tv bill
when it all went black for as long as it
did i swear they all looked at me they
said what the hell's the matter with you
i'm like what are you talking about like
that's literally what happened to me
you know oh my goodness oh yeah i think
that's not that's not uncommon i know
right so you had just mentioned sports
are are you a sports fan of any type are
you you're a native new yorker um
yeah you know i i'm not i'm not a huge
perspective just because i just never my
schedule is always so
uh crazy i can never like keep up with
anything and then i you know then i lose
track and then i don't you know know
who's playing what about uh what about
growing up what about growing up in new
york city uh you know yeah growing up in
new york city i mean obviously
you know the the mets uh was you know
formidable and
informative experience for me you know
the vets and then the giants
uh and i was
probably around 10 years old
when those two teams were
had their
remarkable seizures you're talking about
that like the dwight gooden mats and the
bill parcells phil sims giants that's
right around around the 80s is what
you're talking about right there so you
know so you know
that
that won my lifelong allegiance
okay
mets giants are usually not it you know
usually from a certain era it's like
mets jets giants yankees so you're a
hybrid i know you're a hybrid
i don't know we could see that in your
work uh
corey before i let you go i got to ask
you about your role of mike prince and
billions you're terrific in it um
what is it like you know
locking horns
um in this show with paul giamatti and
damien lewis in these scenes it just is
really intense for me sitting here i
wonder what it's like for you
what you're doing oh it's it's a it's a
blast you know it's just like when you
you know play tennis with somebody who's
better than you you just you get better
um
and you know the writing is so
it's so sharp it's so smart and so it's
so
muscular um so
you know we
we just have a lot of fun uh and
especially those those scenes
um where you have these
these
gladiators yeah that's gone that dead we
haven't they don't give you those pop
culture one-liner uh lines i haven't
heard many of them from your character
normally you know they're coming they're
coming okay all right i look forward to
it um hey corey thanks for the call
really appreciate it um
and i can't wait to see what you're what
you're cooking up uh with david chase
and the rest of the crew and the many
saints of newark a big time fan and i
appreciate the call thanks a lot you got
it that's corey stahl everybody right
here on the rich eisen show the many
saints of newark available in theaters
and on hbo max on october 1st right here
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here